أهلاً بكم مجدداً في فهم المعلومات والحوسبة الكمية، اسمي John Wattrus وأنا المدير التقني للتعليم في IBM Quantum
هذا هو الدرس الثالث عشر في السلسلة وهو الدرس الأول في الوحدة الرابعة والأخيرة التي تتناول تصحيح الأخطاء
الكمية. الحوسبة الكمية لديها القدرة على تمكين حلول فعّالة لمهام حسابية لا تُعرف لها
خوارزميات كلاسيكية فعّالة وربما لا توجد أصلاً. لكن هناك تحديات كبيرة جداً
يجب التغلب عليها إذا أردنا تنفيذ حوسبة كمية واسعة النطاق التي نأمل أن تصبح يوماً ما
ممكنة. جوهر المسألة هو أن المعلومات الكمية هشّة للغاية، يمكنك حرفياً إفسادها بمجرد
النظر إليها. ولذلك لكي تعمل الحواسيب الكمية بشكل صحيح، تحتاج إلى عزل المعلومات الكمية التي
تخزنها عن البيئة المحيطة بها بدرجة شديدة. لكن في نفس الوقت يجب أن يوفر لنا الحاسوب الكمي
تحكماً دقيقاً جداً في هذه المعلومات الكمية، وهذا يشمل التهيئة الصحيحة والعمليات الأحادية الدقيقة والموثوقة
والقدرة بالطبع على إجراء القياسات حتى نتمكن فعلاً من الحصول على نتائج
الحساب. من الواضح أن هناك توتراً بين هذه المتطلبات، وفي الأيام الأولى للحوسبة الكمية كان هناك من يرى أن هشاشة
المعلومات الكمية وقابليتها للتأثر بعدم الدقة والضوضاء البيئية ستجعل في النهاية
الحوسبة الكمية مستحيلة. اليوم لا يوجد شك كبير في أن بناء حاسوب كمي دقيق وموثوق
واسع النطاق هو تحدٍّ ضخم، لكن لدينا أداة أساسية تساعدنا في هذا المسعى وتجعل معظم
المتخصصين في المجال متفائلين بأن الحوسبة الكمية واسعة النطاق ستصبح حقيقة يوماً ما، وهذه الأداة هي تصحيح الأخطاء
الكمية. في الدروس الأربعة القادمة سنناقش تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية مع التركيز على
الأساسيات. في هذا الدرس سنلقي نظرة أولى على تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية بما في ذلك أحد أوائل شفرات تصحيح الأخطاء
الكمية المكتشفة وهي شفرة Shore ذات الـ 9 qubit، وسنناقش أيضاً مفهوماً أساسياً آخر في تصحيح الأخطاء
الكمية يُعرف بتكميم الأخطاء. في الدروس اللاحقة من الوحدة سنرى بنى شفرات تصحيح أخطاء كمية أكثر تطوراً وأفضل في النهاية
وسنناقش أيضاً مشكلة الحساب الكمي على معلومات كمية مشفّرة باستخدام
مكونات حسابية هي نفسها غير مثالية ومعرّضة للأخطاء. إليكم نظرة عامة موجزة على
الدرس. سنبدأ بمناقشة شفرات التكرار الكلاسيكية التي تُعدّ ربما أبسط وأكثر أنواع
شفرات تصحيح الأخطاء الكلاسيكية أساسية. شفرات التكرار الكلاسيكية ليست شفرات جيدة بشكل خاص وفقاً لمعايير
نظرية الترميز الكلاسيكية على الأقل بمفردها، لكن لا بأس بذلك هنا فنحن نسعى للبساطة وبشكل خاص
سنلقي نظرة على أبسط شفرة تصحيح أخطاء كلاسيكية يمكن تخيّلها تقريباً، والتي سنستخدمها بعد ذلك كأساس لمثال بسيط
على شفرة تصحيح أخطاء كمية. ذلك المثال هو شفرة Shore ذات الـ 9 qubit التي سنناقشها بالتفصيل
بما في ذلك وصف الشفرة نفسها وإجراءات ترميز الـ qubit باستخدام هذه الشفرة واكتشاف الأخطاء على الـ qubit المشفّرة و
تصحيح تلك الأخطاء. وفي الجزء الثالث من الدرس سنناقش تكميم الأخطاء الذي يسمح لنا بالتفكير في أخطاء عشوائية على
الـ qubit والتي تشكّل من حيث المبدأ طيفاً متصلاً من الاحتمالات بمصطلحات منفصلة، وذلك باختزال الأخطاء أساساً إلى
ما يُسمى بانقلابات البت وانقلابات الطور. قبل أن ندخل في التفاصيل التقنية لتصحيح الأخطاء الكمية
من المفيد التوقف لحظة للتفكير في الحاجة لتصحيح الأخطاء الكمية وكذلك تصحيح الأخطاء
الكلاسيكية. كما أشرت في بداية الدرس، الحواسيب الكمية معرّضة بشكل كبير للأخطاء بسبب
هشاشة المعلومات الكمية. بشكل خاص التفاعلات غير المرغوبة مع البيئة أو بعبارة
أخرى بقية العالم يمكن أن تُزعج المعلومات الكمية. هذه التفاعلات غير المرغوبة يمكن أن تسبب فك الترابط حيث تتسرب المعلومات
بشكل أساسي إلى البيئة مما يجعل المعلومات المخزنة في الحاسوب الكمي تتصرف بشكل
كلاسيكي أكثر فأكثر. ومن المهم جداً أيضاً أن ندرك أن العمليات الكمية لا يمكن تنفيذها إلا بدقة
محدودة. مثلاً قد نرغب في تنفيذ gate كمي معين على qubit لكن لأن الأجهزة الفيزيائية
ليست مثالية أبداً فإن ما ننفذه فعلياً قد يكون مجرد تقريب لذلك الـ gate. قد لا يكون ذلك مشكلة كبيرة لـ
gate واحد، لكن إذا كانت نيتنا تنفيذ آلاف أو ملايين الـ gate الكمية فإن عدم الدقة الصغير هذا سيبدأ
بالتراكم وعندما ينتهي الحساب قد نحصل على حالة مختلفة جداً عما
توقعنا. فهذا مصدر مختلف تماماً للأخطاء لكنه بالتأكيد مصدر لا يمكننا
تجاهله. يدرس الناس شفرات تصحيح الأخطاء الكلاسيكية منذ ما يقارب قرناً ولهذه الشفرات تطبيقات كثيرة بما في ذلك في
نقل وتخزين المعلومات. لكن لأن مكونات الحوسبة الكلاسيكية موثوقة جداً فنحن لا نحتاج فعلاً
تصحيح الأخطاء لبناء حواسيب كلاسيكية. الآن قد يكون من الممكن أن تصحيح الأخطاء ليس ضرورياً فعلاً
لبناء حواسيب كمية موثوقة واسعة النطاق أيضاً. مثلاً الفكرة الرئيسية وراء الحوسبة الكمية
الطوبولوجية هي أنه قد يكون من الممكن بناء أنظمة كمية متينة محمية بطبيعتها من الضوضاء بسبب
الخصائص الطوبولوجية للأنظمة. لكننا لا نعرف إن كان ذلك ممكناً ويُعتقد على نطاق واسع
أن تصحيح الأخطاء سيكون ضرورياً على الأرجح بشكل أو بآخر للحوسبة الكمية واسعة النطاق. الآن سنناقش شفرات
التكرار الكلاسيكية التي تشكّل الأساس لأول شفرة تصحيح أخطاء كمية لدينا وهي شفرة Shore ذات الـ 9 qubit التي
سنراها قريباً. شفرات التكرار هي أمثلة أساسية جداً على شفرات تصحيح الأخطاء
الفكرة هي أنه يمكننا حماية البتات من الأخطاء بتكرار كل بت عدداً معيناً من المرات. بشكل خاص لنلقِ نظرة على
شفرة التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات. هنا نشفّر بتاً واحداً في ثلاثة بتكرار البت ثلاث مرات فيصبح
الصفر مشفّراً كـ 000 والواحد مشفّر كـ 111. بالطبع إذا لم يحدث خطأ يمكننا
التمييز بسهولة بين الاحتمالين. لكن إذا حدث خطأ وانقلب أحد البتات لنقل
أن الصفر يتحول إلى واحد أو الواحد يتحول إلى صفر فلا يزال بإمكاننا معرفة ما كان البت الأصلي
بالنظر إلى أي من القيمتين الثنائيتين تظهر مرتين. بالتكافؤ يمكننا فك التشفير بحساب قيمة الأغلبية
أو بعبارة أخرى القيمة الثنائية التي تظهر بأكبر تكرار. ومن السهل ملاحظة أنه
إذا كان لدينا انقلاب بت واحد على الأكثر فإن فك التشفير سيكون صحيحاً. بالطبع إذا انقلب بتّان أو
انقلبت البتات الثلاثة جميعها فلن يعمل وسنحصل على القيمة الخاطئة عند فك التشفير. وهذه خاصية عامة
تمتلكها كل شفرة تصحيح أخطاء: قد تتمكن من تصحيح بعض الأخطاء لكنك لن تتمكن أبداً من تصحيح كل خطأ. وفي النهاية الأمر
يتعلق بتقليل فرصة حدوث خطأ بدلاً من ضمان الصحة وهو أمر غير ممكن عموماً
كمثال على حالة يمكننا فيها تقليل فرصة حدوث خطأ، لنفترض أن
هدفنا هو إرسال بت واحد إلى مستقبِل افتراضي، وللقيام بذلك يمكننا إرسال بتات عبر
ما يُسمى بالقناة الثنائية المتماثلة التي تقلب كل بت يُرسل عبرها بشكل مستقل باحتمال
معين P. فباحتمال 1 ناقص P سيحصل المستقبِل على البت الذي نوينا إرساله، لكن باحتمال P
ينقلب البت ويحصل المستقبِل على القيمة المعاكسة لما أرسلناه. فإذا لم نستخدم شفرة
التكرار وبدلاً من ذلك أرسلنا فقط البت الذي في ذهننا عبر القناة، سيحصل المستقبِل على البت الخاطئ
باحتمال P. من ناحية أخرى إذا شفّرنا أولاً البت الذي نريد إرساله باستخدام شفرة التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات و
ثم أرسلنا كل بت من البتات الثلاثة المشفّرة عبر القناة، فكل واحد منها ينقلب باحتمال P إذن
فرص انقلاب بت أصبحت أكبر لأن لدينا الآن ثلاثة بتات قد تنقلب بدلاً من واحد
لكن إذا انقلب بت واحد على الأكثر فسيتمكن المستقبِل من فك التشفير بشكل صحيح. فلن نحصل على خطأ بعد
فك التشفير إلا إذا انقلب بتّان أو أكثر أثناء الإرسال. ومن السهل حساب أن ذلك يحدث باحتمال
3 ضرب P تربيع ناقص 2 ضرب P تكعيب. لقيم P الأصغر من 1/2
يؤدي هذا إلى انخفاض في احتمال أن يحصل المستقبِل على البت الخاطئ. ستظل هناك فرصة لحدوث خطأ في هذه الحالة لكن
الشفرة تقلل من احتمالية ذلك. وإذا أردت تقليل الفرصة أكثر يمكنك فعل ذلك باستخدام
شفرة مختلفة بما في ذلك على سبيل المثال لا الحصر إمكانية استخدام شفرة تكرار حيث يُكرر البت المشفّر
أكثر من ثلاث مرات. لقيم P الأكبر من 1/2 بالمناسبة الشفرة تجعل
الأمور أسوأ بمعنى أنها تزيد من احتمال أن يحصل المستقبِل على البت الخاطئ، لذا بالتأكيد لن نستخدم هذه الشفرة في تلك
الحالة. شفرة التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات هي شفرة تصحيح أخطاء كلاسيكية، لكن يمكننا أيضاً النظر في ما يحدث إذا
حاولنا استخدامها لحماية الـ qubit من الأخطاء. إنها ليست شفرة تصحيح أخطاء كمية جيدة جداً كما سنرى، فهي
تستطيع التصحيح ضد بعض الأخطاء لكنها تجعل أخطاء أخرى أكثر احتمالاً. لكنها الخطوة الأولى نحو شفرة Shore
فلنرَ كيف تعمل مع الـ qubit. أولاً للتوضيح عندما نتحدث عن استخدام شفرة التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات
مع الـ qubit ما نعنيه هو ترميز qubit كما هو موضح على الشاشة حيث ألفا 0 زائد بيتا 1 يُشفّر
كـ ألفا 000 زائد بيتا 111. بعبارة أخرى حالة الأساس القياسي
تُكرر ثلاث مرات. لاحظ بشكل خاص أن هذا ليس نفس الشيء كتكرار الحالة الكمية ثلاث مرات كأن نأخذ
حالة كمية معينة s ونشفّرها كـ s تنسور s تنسور s وهو ترميز لن نتمكن من
تنفيذه لحالة كمية مجهولة s بسبب نظرية عدم الاستنساخ. أما الترميز الذي نتحدث
عنه فيمكن تنفيذه بسهولة بالغة. إليكم circuit كمي بسيط جداً ينفذه باستخدام اثنين من qubit مساحة العمل المهيّأة واثنين من
gate التحكم-NOT. الآن لنفترض أن خطأً يحدث بعد الترميز
وبشكل خاص لنفترض أن عملية poly-X أو بعبارة أخرى انقلاب بت يحدث على أحد
الـ qubit وفي هذا الشكل هو الـ qubit الأوسط. بالطبع هذا ليس النوع الوحيد من الأخطاء الممكنة وقد
تعترض على فكرة أن الخطأ يأخذ شكل هذه العملية الأحادية المثالية، لكننا سنعود لهذا لاحقاً في الدرس والآن يمكننا
التفكير فيه كمثال فقط. إليكم الحالة الناتجة: إنها نفس الترميز الأصلي باستثناء
أن البت الأوسط في كل ket قد انقلب. واضح أنه يمكننا رؤية ذلك من التعبيرات الرياضية للحالة
لكن افترض أنه كان لدينا فقط الثلاثة qubit وأننا نشتبه في أن انقلاب بت قد حدث لكننا لا نعرف أي qubit قد تأثر
إحدى الطرق لمعرفة ما إذا حدث انقلاب بت هي إجراء قياس الأساس القياسي وفحص النتيجة. في هذه الحالة سنرى
إما 010 أو 101 باحتمالات تعتمد على ألفا وبيتا، وفي كلتا الحالتين استنتاجنا
سيكون أن البت الأوسط انقلب. لكن للأسف هذا يدمر الحالة الكمية الأصلية وهذه الحالة
قد تكون ثمينة بالنسبة لنا، فالهدف كله هو حماية هذه الحالة الكمية لذا هذا ليس خياراً
جيداً. ما يمكننا فعله بدلاً من ذلك هو استخدام الـ circuit الكمي الموضح هنا على الشاشة حيث ندخل الحالة المشفّرة
في الثلاثة qubit العلوية. ما يفعله الـ circuit أساساً هو حساب التكافؤ لحالات
الأساس القياسي للـ qubit العلويين وكذلك للـ qubit السفليين من الترميز وهذا سيكشف
موقع انقلاب البت. بشكل خاص في هذه الحالة سنحصل على النتيجة واحد لكلا فحصي التكافؤ ومن
تلك المعلومات يمكننا استنتاج أن البت الأوسط هو المختلف عن الآخرين وبالتالي هو الذي
انقلب. والأهم من ذلك أن هذا لا يسبب انهيار الحالة، فلدينا الآن فرصة لمحاولة تصحيح هذا
الانقلاب حتى نتمكن في النهاية ربما من فك التشفير واستعادة حالتنا الأصلية. سنعود إلى التصحيح
بعد قليل لكن أولاً لنأخذ لمحة سريعة عن الاحتمالات الأخرى لخطأ انقلاب بت. إذا حدث خطأ انقلاب البت
على الـ qubit السفلي أو الأيسر فسنحصل على النتيجة 10 بالقراءة من الأسفل للأعلى ومجدداً
الحالة لن تتغير. وإذا حدث انقلاب البت على الـ qubit العلوي فستكون النتيجة
01 ومرة أخرى الحالة لا تتغير. وبالمناسبة إذا لم يحدث
خطأ انقلاب بت أصلاً فنتيجة القياس هي 00 ومجدداً تخرج الحالة بدون تغيير
فلنلخص كل هذا في شكل جدول حيث نسرد كل حالة ممكنة نحصل عليها من انقلاب بت واحد على الأكثر ونتائج القياس
التي نسميها المتلازمة في سياق تصحيح الأخطاء والتصحيح الذي نحتاجه لاستعادة الترميز
الأصلي. إذا لم يكن هناك خطأ تكون المتلازمة 00 ولا حاجة لفعل شيء لإصلاح
الحالة. إذا تعرض الـ qubit السفلي أو الأيسر لانقلاب بت تكون المتلازمة 10 والتصحيح المناسب
هو تطبيق gate X على الـ qubit السفلي أو الأيسر. والحالتان الأخريان
مماثلتان. فإذا طبقنا التصحيح المناسب بناءً على المتلازمة سنتمكن بالتأكيد من استعادة الترميز
الأصلي في جميع الحالات الأربع. مرة أخرى نحن نأخذ بالاعتبار فقط إمكانية أن خطأ انقلاب
بت واحد على الأكثر قد حدث. هذا لن يعمل بشكل صحيح إذا انقلب بتّان أو ثلاثة ولم نأخذ أيضاً بالاعتبار
إمكانية أخطاء أخرى. الآن لننظر في نوع مختلف من الأخطاء في السياق الكمي. أخطاء انقلاب
البت ليست الأخطاء الوحيدة التي نحتاج القلق بشأنها، مثلاً يجب أن نقلق أيضاً بشأن أخطاء انقلاب
الطور أو ببساطة انقلابات الطور والتي تُوصف بـ gate Z أو بالتكافؤ عمليات poly-Z
للأسف شفرة التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات تفشل تماماً في اكتشاف انقلابات الطور. مثلاً لو
شفّرنا qubit باستخدام شفرة التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات كما فعلنا سابقاً وحدث خطأ انقلاب طور على الـ qubit
الأوسط سنحصل على الحالة الموضحة على الشاشة وهي بالضبط الترميز الذي كنا سنحصل عليه لو
حدث انقلاب طور على الـ qubit الأصلي قبل الترميز. وبالتالي إذا نفذنا نفس
الـ circuit كما سبق لمحاولة اكتشاف خطأ سنحصل على المتلازمة 00 التي تشير خطأً إلى عدم حدوث أي أخطاء
إذن شفرة التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات تعمل لخطأ انقلاب بت واحد على الأكثر لكنها تفشل في اكتشاف أخطاء انقلاب الطور. في
الواقع هي تجعل الأمور أسوأ بمعنى ما لأن لدينا الآن ثلاثة أضعاف عدد الـ qubit التي يمكن أن تتعرض لأخطاء انقلاب
الطور. لاحظنا أن شفرة التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات غافلة تماماً عن أخطاء انقلاب الطور فهي لا تبدو
مفيدة جداً للتعامل مع هذا النوع من الأخطاء. لكن في الواقع يمكننا تعديل شفرة التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات بحيث
تكتشف أخطاء انقلاب الطور وسأشرح الآن كيف يمكن فعل ذلك. إليكم الـ circuit الأصلي لـ
ترميز qubit باستخدام شفرة التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات والطريقة التي سنعدّلها بها بسيطة جداً، نطبق فقط
gate Hadamard على كل qubit من الترميز. gate Hadamard يحوّل حالة الصفر إلى حالة زائد وحالة الواحد
إلى حالة ناقص. فالنتيجة الصافية هي أننا نحصل على الحالة الموضحة على الشاشة حيث
زائد زائد زائد وناقص ناقص ناقص هي اختصارات لتنسور ثلاث حالات زائد أو ثلاث حالات ناقص
خطأ انقلاب الطور أو بعبارة أخرى gate Z يحوّل حالات زائد إلى حالات ناقص وحالات ناقص إلى
حالات زائد. فهذا الترميز سيكون مفيداً لاكتشاف وتصحيح أخطاء انقلاب الطور وللقيام بذلك يمكننا
تعديل circuit اكتشاف الأخطاء السابق بالطريقة التالية. إليكم الـ circuit السابق وما سنفعله هو
ببساطة وضع gate Hadamard في البداية والنهاية كما هو موضح على الشاشة
الفكرة بسيطة جداً. الثلاثة gate Hadamard الأولى تحوّل حالات زائد وناقص مرة أخرى إلى حالات صفر وواحد
ونفس فحوصات التكافؤ كما سبق تتم ثم الطبقة الثانية من gate Hadamard تعيدنا إلى
ترميزنا. طريقة أخرى للتفكير في هذا هي أننا نحوّل أساساً أخطاء انقلاب الطور إلى أخطاء انقلاب البت عبر الاقتران بعمليات Hadamard
يمكننا بالمناسبة تبسيط الـ circuit قليلاً. هذا الـ circuit هنا مكافئ تماماً
ويمكنك التحقق من ذلك بنفسك إن أردت. فإذا أدخلنا الـ qubit المشفّر في هذا الـ circuit بافتراض
عدم حدوث أخطاء انقلاب طور نحصل على المتلازمة 00 مما يشير إلى عدم وجود أخطاء انقلاب
طور. وإذا كان لدينا خطأ انقلاب طور على الـ qubit العلوي مثلاً فإن حالات زائد وناقص الأيمن تنقلب
وهذا ينتج متلازمة خطأ مختلفة 01 في هذه الحالة. وهذا يحدد موقع انقلاب الطور تماماً كما
كان الحال مع انقلاب البت ويمكننا تصحيحه بتطبيق gate Z على الـ qubit العلوي. والوضع
مماثل لأخطاء انقلاب الطور على أي من الـ qubit الآخرين. فيمكننا فعلاً اكتشاف و
تصحيح خطأ انقلاب طور واحد على الأكثر باستخدام هذه الشفرة. لكن للأسف كما قد تكون خمنت لم نعد قادرين على
تصحيح أخطاء انقلاب البت. لكن لم نخسر كل شيء لأنه يمكننا فعلاً دمج هاتين الشفرتين
معاً للحصول على شفرة تستطيع تصحيح كل من أخطاء انقلاب البت وانقلاب الطور. وفي الواقع ستتمكن من
التصحيح ضد أي خطأ على qubit واحد. حان الوقت الآن لمناقشة شفرة Shore ذات الـ 9 qubit وهي شفرة تصحيح
أخطاء كمية يمكننا الحصول عليها بدمج الشفرتين اللتين رأيناهما للتو، أي شفرة التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات
التي تسمح بتصحيح خطأ انقلاب بت واحد والنسخة المعدّلة منها التي تسمح بتصحيح خطأ انقلاب طور
واحد. بشكل أدق شفرة Shore ذات الـ 9 qubit هي الشفرة التي نحصل عليها بتسلسل الشفرتين مما يعني
أننا نطبق أولاً ترميزاً واحداً يشفّر qubit واحد إلى ثلاثة ثم نطبق الترميز الآخر على كل من
الثلاثة qubit بشكل مستقل فنحصل على تسعة qubit إجمالاً. يمكننا التعبير عن هذا في شكل
مخطط circuit كالتالي. أولاً نطبق النسخة المعدّلة من شفرة التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات
التي تكتشف أخطاء انقلاب الطور ثم نشفّر كل qubit من الـ qubit الناتجة بشكل مستقل باستخدام شفرة
التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات الأصلية. فإذا صغّرنا هذا الـ circuit قليلاً لتوفير مساحة يمكننا
تحديد الشفرة بمصطلحات مختلفة نوعاً ما من خلال وصف كيف يتم ترميز حالتي الأساس القياسي للـ qubit
الأصلي وبمجرد أن نعرف ذلك يمكننا تحديد بالخطية كيف يتم ترميز متجه حالة qubit عشوائي
فهذه هي شفرة Shore ذات الـ 9 qubit والفكرة هي أن إحدى الشفرتين تسمح لنا بتصحيح أخطاء انقلاب
الطور والأخرى تسمح لنا بتصحيح أخطاء انقلاب البت وكما سنرى فإن ذلك يعني فعلاً أنه يمكننا
تصحيح أي خطأ عشوائي على qubit واحد. الآن لنرَ كيف يمكننا اكتشاف وتصحيح الأخطاء باستخدام شفرة Shore ذات الـ 9 qubit
بدءاً بأخطاء انقلاب البت والتي تسمى أيضاً أخطاء X. إليكم الـ circuit الذي ينفذ
الترميز ولتسهيل الحديث سنفكر في الـ 9 qubit التي نحصل عليها من هذه الشفرة على أنها
مجمّعة في ثلاث كتل من ثلاثة qubit حيث تمثل كل كتلة الترميز الذي نحصل عليه من تطبيق
خطوة الترميز الثانية وهي شفرة التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات العادية والتي تسمى الشفرة الداخلية في
هذا السياق بينما الشفرة الخارجية هي الشفرة المستخدمة في خطوة الترميز الأولى وهي في هذه الحالة النسخة
المعدّلة من شفرة التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات التي تعمل مع أخطاء انقلاب الطور. لتصحيح أخطاء انقلاب البت يمكننا
ببساطة التعامل مع كل كتلة على حدة. كل كتلة هي ترميز لـ qubit باستخدام شفرة التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات
وتلك الشفرة تحمي ضد أخطاء انقلاب البت. لنفترض أولاً أن خطأ X يحدث على أي qubit من الـ qubit
مثل الـ qubit الأوسط في الكتلة الوسطى. إذا فحصنا كل كتلة بشكل مستقل بحثاً عن أخطاء انقلاب البت و
صححنا أي أخطاء نجدها فسيتم تصحيح هذا الخطأ واستعادة الترميز الأصلي
في الواقع يمكن أن يكون لدينا عدة أخطاء X ولا نزال نصححها بهذه الطريقة بشرط أن تكون الأخطاء
في كتل منفصلة. إذا كان لدينا خطأان أو ثلاثة أخطاء X في كتلة واحدة فسنكون في مشكلة لكن
طالما أن هناك خطأ X واحد على الأكثر في كل كتلة فإن الشفرة الداخلية ستكتشفه وسنتمكن من استعادة الحالة المشفّرة
الأصلية. فتصحيح أخطاء انقلاب البت أمر بسيط جداً لهذه الشفرة. نحتاج أيضاً النظر في أخطاء انقلاب الطور
أو بعبارة أخرى أخطاء Z. هذه المرة ليس واضحاً تماماً ما يجب فعله لأن الشفرة الخارجية هي التي
تصحح أخطاء انقلاب الطور لكننا لا نستطيع اكتشافها وتصحيحها مباشرة لأن الشفرة الداخلية تقف بطريقة ما
في الطريق. لكننا سنرى كيف نفعل ذلك قريباً. لفهم أفضل لكيفية عمل أخطاء X و Z
والتأثيرات التي تحدثها داخل الـ circuit الكمية، من المفيد ملاحظة بعض العلاقات البسيطة بين هذه الأخطاء و gate
التحكم-NOT وهذا سيكون مفيداً أيضاً في درس لاحق. أولاً لنبدأ بأخطاء X
أو gate X وكيف ترتبط بـ gate التحكم-NOT. إذا طبقنا gate X على
الـ qubit الهدف في gate تحكم-NOT ثم طبقنا gate التحكم-NOT فذلك يكافئ عكس الترتيب وتنفيذ gate التحكم-NOT
أولاً. من ناحية أخرى إذا طبقنا gate X على الـ qubit المتحكم في gate تحكم-NOT ثم طبقنا gate التحكم-NOT فلا يمكننا ببساطة
عكس الترتيب بل يجب تطبيق gate X على كلا الـ qubit. ويمكنك التحقق من كل هذه العلاقات
بنفسك إن أردت بالتفكير في ما يحدث لحالات الأساس القياسي مثلاً. الوضع مماثل لأخطاء Z
باستثناء أن أدوار الـ qubit المتحكم والهدف تتبادل. بشكل خاص إذا نفذنا
gate Z على الـ qubit المتحكم في gate تحكم-NOT ثم نفذنا gate التحكم-NOT فذلك له نفس تأثير تنفيذ
gate Z بعد gate التحكم-NOT. لكن إذا نفذنا gate Z على الـ qubit الهدف بدلاً من ذلك فذلك
يكافئ تنفيذ gate التحكم-NOT أولاً ثم تطبيق gate Z على كلا الـ qubit. وأخيراً كل هذه
العلاقات متماثلة بمعنى أنه يمكننا دائماً عكس ترتيب الـ gate على جانبي كل معادلة
وهو ما يكافئ أخذ المعكوس أو المرافق المنقول لكلا الجانبين بالنظر إلى أن gate X و Z و التحكم-NOT
كلها معكوسات لنفسها. الآن لننظر في أخطاء انقلاب الطور وكيف يمكننا اكتشافها وتصحيحها
باستخدام شفرة Shore ذات الـ 9 qubit. إليكم circuit الترميز وسنستمر في التفكير في الـ 9
qubit المستخدمة في الترميز على أنها مجمّعة في ثلاث كتل من ثلاثة qubit. لنفترض أن خطأ Z يحدث على
أي qubit مثل الذي هو مشار إليه هنا. باستخدام ما لاحظناه للتو عن gate Z
و gate التحكم-NOT فذلك يكافئ خطأي Z قبل gate التحكم-NOT واحد على
المتحكم وواحد على الـ qubit الهدف. وهذه الأخطاء تتبادل مع gate التحكم-NOT الأخرى في الكتلة فيمكننا
عكس الترتيب وهذا ما نحصل عليه. خطأ Z السفلي لا يفعل شيئاً لأنه يعمل على حالة
صفر ويمكننا تمرير كل شيء آخر وإليكم هذا المخطط. فما وجدناه هو أن خطأ Z في مكان ما داخل
الكتلة الوسطى يكافئ حدوث خطأ Z على الـ qubit الأوسط قبل مرحلة الترميز الثانية و
يمكنك الاستدلال بنفس الطريقة تماماً لخطأ Z على أي من الـ qubit. انقلاب طور على أي qubit داخل كتلة
يكافئ انقلاب طور على الـ qubit المقابل قبل الترميز الداخلي. وهذا في الواقع بديهي جداً إذا
فكرت في كيف تؤثر أخطاء Z على شفرة التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات. فأحد الخيارات للتعامل مع خطأ
Z هو فك ترميز الشفرة الداخلية ثم اكتشاف وتصحيح أخطاء Z باستخدام الشفرة الخارجية وهي النسخة المعدّلة
من شفرة التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات التي يمكنها تصحيح خطأ Z. فهذا يصحح خطأ Z و
يمكننا إعادة الترميز بالشفرة الداخلية إذا أردنا ذلك. يمكننا أيضاً تصحيح أخطاء Z
في مكانها إذا جاز التعبير دون فك الترميز وإعادة الترميز ولشرح كيف يمكننا
فعل ذلك سنحتاج مساحة أكبر قليلاً. لنفترض أننا نفك ترميز الشفرة الداخلية
ثم نحسب المتلازمة للشفرة الخارجية بنفس الطريقة السابقة حيث نتعامل فقط مع الثلاثة qubit من الشفرة الخارجية و
ثم نعيد الترميز. يمكننا تبسيط كل gate التحكم-NOT هذه قليلاً وفي الواقع
يمكننا استخدام العلاقات بين gate NOT و gate التحكم-NOT التي لاحظناها منذ لحظات للمساعدة في ذلك
وبفعل ذلك يمكننا توفير أربعة gate تحكم-NOT وهذا هو الـ circuit الذي نحصل عليه. إذا حدث خطأ Z على أحد
الـ qubit فما تخبرنا به المتلازمة الآن ليس أي qubit تعرض لخطأ Z بل في أي كتلة حدث
خطأ Z. لكن لا بأس لأننا نعلم أنه لا يهم أي qubit داخل الكتلة يتعرض لخطأ Z فـ
التأثير هو نفسه لجميع الـ qubit الثلاثة داخل تلك الكتلة ولذلك يمكننا فعلاً تصحيح خطأ Z بتطبيق gate Z على أي من
الـ qubit داخل تلك الكتلة. هذا بالمناسبة مثال على ما يسمى بالانحلال في شفرة تصحيح
أخطاء حيث لا نحدد بشكل فريد خطأً معيناً لكننا قادرون على تصحيحه على أي حال. أخيراً لنفترض أن كلاً من
خطأ انقلاب بت وخطأ انقلاب طور يحدثان ربما على نفس الـ qubit. مثلاً لنفترض أن
خطأ انقلاب بت وخطأ انقلاب طور يحدثان على هذا الـ qubit هنا. كما يتبين يمكن اكتشاف هذه الأخطاء
وتصحيحها بشكل مستقل تماماً وفي الواقع لا يهم إذا صححنا كل كتلة من انقلاب
البت أولاً ثم صححنا انقلابات الطور أو إذا فعلنا ذلك بالعكس. لرؤية ذلك لنلاحظ أولاً
أن ترتيب هذه الأخطاء لا يهم فيمكننا عكسها إن شئنا. السبب ليس أن
X و Z تتبادلان لأنهما لا تتبادلان فـ X ضرب Z يساوي سالب Z ضرب X لكن
عامل سالب 1 ليس له تأثير في هذه الحالة لأنه طور شامل. يمكننا الآن تحريك خطأ Z كما
سبق وعند هذه النقطة يتضح أنه لو صححنا أولاً كل كتلة من أخطاء X ثم صححنا
أخطاء Z فسنكون قد صححنا كلا الخطأين. بدلاً من ذلك إذا قررنا لسبب ما
تصحيح أخطاء Z أولاً يمكننا فعل ذلك وخطأ X ليس له أي تأثير في تلك العملية
يجب أن يكون ذلك صحيحاً لأن أولاً خطأ X يتبادل مع كل gate في الـ circuit الذي يحسب
المتلازمة للشفرة الخارجية وثانياً الترتيب بين خطأ X و gate Z الذي نطبقه لإجراء
التصحيح لا يهم تماماً كما جادلنا عندما كان gate Z خطأً. فذلك يسمح بتصحيح خطأ
Z ويمكننا بعد ذلك تصحيح كل كتلة لإزالة خطأ X. فما جادلنا به هو أنه
يمكننا تصحيح خطأ X أو خطأ Z أو كليهما على أي qubit واحد من الـ qubit باستخدام هذه الشفرة
في الواقع يمكننا تصحيح أخطاء أكثر من ذلك مثل عدة أخطاء X طالما وقعت في كتل مختلفة
أو عدة أخطاء Z طالما أن كتلة واحدة على الأكثر تحصل على عدد فردي منها. لكن فيما يأتي الأهم
هو أنه يمكننا تصحيح خطأ X أو خطأ Z أو كليهما على أي qubit واحد. وفي الجزء الأخير من الدرس
سنرى كيف أن هذا يكفي فعلاً للاستنتاج أن هذه الشفرة تستطيع تصحيح أي خطأ عشوائي على أي
qubit واحد. قبل أن ننتقل إلى الجزء الأخير من الدرس الذي سنتناول فيه الأخطاء الكمية العشوائية سنأخذ بإيجاز
نظرة على أداء شفرة Shore ذات الـ 9 qubit عندما تحدث أخطاء ممثلة بمصفوفات poly بشكل عشوائي على
الـ qubit. بشكل أكثر تحديداً لننظر في نموذج ضوضاء بسيط حيث تحدث الأخطاء بشكل مستقل على الـ qubit
مع تعرّض كل qubit لخطأ باحتمال P وبدون أي ارتباط بين الأخطاء على مختلف
الـ qubit. أسوأ سيناريو لشفرة Shore ذات الـ 9 qubit هو أن خطأ Y أو بعبارة أخرى كلا خطأ X وخطأ Z
يحدث على كل qubit متأثر وسنفترض هذا السيناريو الأسوأ فقط من أجل الحصول على حدّ
على أداء الشفرة. لكن يمكنك أيضاً أن تفترض مثلاً أن أخطاء poly الثلاثة متساوية
الاحتمال. الآن لنفترض أن Q هو qubit في حالة معينة نريد حمايتها من الأخطاء وتخيل أن
لدينا خيار استخدام شفرة Shore ذات الـ 9 qubit. هل يجب أن نستخدمها؟ الجواب ليس بالضرورة
نعم لأنه إذا كان هناك ضوضاء كثيرة أو بعبارة أخرى P كبيرة جداً فاستخدام شفرة Shore قد يجعل الأمور
أسوأ فعلاً تماماً كما كان الحال مع شفرة التكرار عندما تكون P أكبر من 1/2. لكن إذا كانت P صغيرة بما فيه الكفاية فـ
الجواب نعم يجب أن نستخدم الشفرة. فلنرَ لماذا هذا هو الحال وماذا يعني أن تكون P كبيرة جداً أو صغيرة
بما فيه الكفاية لهذه الشفرة. شفرة Shore تستطيع تصحيح أي خطأ poly على qubit واحد وفي أسوأ
الحالات حيث أخطاء poly هي أخطاء Y فهذا يعني أن الشفرة تحمي Q بنجاح باحتمال معطى بـ
التعبير الموضح على الشاشة. بالتحديد الشفرة تعمل عندما لا توجد أخطاء وهذا يحدث
باحتمال (1 ناقص P) أس 9 لأن هناك تسعة qubit يجب أن لا يتأثر أي منها. وتعمل عندما يوجد
خطأ واحد بالضبط وبالنظر إلى وجود تسعة qubit مختلفة يمكن أن تتأثر فهذا يحدث باحتمال 9 ضرب P ضرب (1 ناقص P) أس 8
من ناحية أخرى إذا لم نكلف أنفسنا عناء استخدام الشفرة فإن الـ qubit الوحيد لدينا سيكون غير متأثر بخطأ
باحتمال 1 ناقص P. فالشفرة تفيد فقط عندما يكون الاحتمال الأول أكبر من الثاني
لأن هذه التعبيرات تمثل احتمالات نجاحنا في الحالتين: عندما نستخدم الشفرة وعندما
لا نستخدمها. إليكم رسماً بيانياً لهاتين الدالتين لقيم P الصغيرة ونجد أن نقطة التعادل تقع عند
حوالي 3 وثلاثة أرباع بالمئة. فإذا كانت P أصغر من هذه القيمة فإن الشفرة
تفيد. عند نقطة التعادل الاحتمالات متساوية فنحن فقط نضيّع وقتنا مع 8 qubit إضافية إذا
استخدمنا الشفرة لكن غير ذلك لا ضرر فيها. وبعد تلك النقطة يجب بالتأكيد ألا نستخدم هذه الشفرة
لأنها فعلاً تزيد فرصة حدوث خطأ على الـ qubit المشفّر الذي نسميه عادة
الـ qubit المنطقي في هذا السياق. وذلك يحدث ببساطة لأن فرصة حدوث خطأين أو أكثر على تسعة qubit
أكبر من فرصة حدوث خطأ واحد على qubit واحد لقيم P في هذا النطاق. 3 وثلاثة أرباع بالمئة قد لا تبدو
جيدة خاصة مقارنة بـ 50% وهي نقطة التعادل المماثلة لشفرة التكرار ذات الثلاث بتات للمعلومات
الكلاسيكية. لكن حماية المعلومات الكمية أصعب وعلاوة على ذلك رغم أن هذه
الشفرة تمثل اكتشافاً رائعاً كأول شفرة تصحيح أخطاء كمية وهي ممتازة لأغراض تعليمية فإن الحقيقة
هي أنها ليست شفرة جيدة جداً من الناحية العملية. حتى الآن تناولنا أخطاء X
وأخطاء Z في سياق شفرة Shore ذات الـ 9 qubit. الآن لننظر في الأخطاء العشوائية
بدءاً أولاً بالأخطاء الأحادية. مثلاً يمكن أن يكون هذا الخطأ دوراناً صغيراً جداً
لكرة Bloch يمثل ربما خطأً ناتجاً عن gate غير مثالي مثلاً
أو يمكن أن يكون أي عملية أحادية أخرى على qubit وليس بالضرورة شيئاً قريباً من عملية الهوية
قد يبدو أن تصحيح مثل هذه الأخطاء صعب. هناك عدد لا نهائي من الأخطاء المحتملة مثل
هذه ومن غير المتصور أن نتمكن بطريقة ما من تحديد الخطأ بالضبط ثم عكسه. لكننا
لا نحتاج فعلاً لفعل شيء مختلف عما ناقشناه بالفعل. طالما نستطيع التصحيح ضد انقلاب بت أو انقلاب طور أو كليهما فإننا
سننجح فعلاً في تصحيح أي خطأ أحادي عشوائي على qubit واحد وسأشرح الآن لماذا
أولاً مثل كل المصفوفات 2×2 يمكننا التعبير عن أي مصفوفة أحادية عشوائية
تمثل خطأ على qubit واحد كتركيبة خطية لمصفوفات poly الأربع بما في ذلك مصفوفة الهوية
وبالمناسبة كما لاحظتم ربما أنا أستخدم X و Y و Z الكبيرة للإشارة إلى مصفوفات poly غير الهوية
وسأستمر في ذلك لبقية هذه السلسلة. هذا هو التقليد في تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية ويجعل
الأمور أسهل للقراءة في هذا السياق. سيكون ملائماً أيضاً استخدام الحواشي السفلية للإشارة إلى
أي qubit تعمل عليه عملية أحادية معينة. مثلاً إذا استخدمنا اصطلاح ترقيم
الـ qubit في Qiskit بدءاً من qubit صفر على اليمين فلدينا التعبيرات الموضحة على الشاشة لـ
عمليات أحادية مختلفة على qubit مفردة حيث في كل حالة نأخذ تنسور المصفوفة الأحادية مع مصفوفة الهوية
على كل qubit آخر. فبشكل خاص يمكننا التعبير عن U_K أي U مطبقة على qubit K كنفس
التركيبة الخطية كما سبق باستثناء أن كل مصفوفة poly مطبقة على qubit K. لا نحتاج لوضع
حاشية سفلية للهوية بالمناسبة. المفهوم هنا هو أن هذه هي الهوية على جميع
الـ qubit. الآن لنفترض أن ψ هي ترميز الـ 9 qubit لحالة qubit. إذا حدث الخطأ U على
qubit K فنحصل على U_K ضرب ψ والذي يمكننا التعبير عنه كتركيبة خطية لعمليات poly تعمل على ψ والتي
هي بالطبع ψ نفسها في حالة الهوية. عند هذه النقطة سيكون مفيداً ملاحظة أن مصفوفة poly Y
تساوي i ضرب X ضرب Z فيمكننا إجراء هذا الاستبدال في
تعبيرنا. فهذا الخطأ قد حدث والآن لنفترض أننا نحاول تصحيحه بنفس الإجراء كما
سبق. الخطوة الأولى هي حساب المتلازمة والتي في حالة شفرة Shore هي 8 بتات، بتّان لكل من
المرات الثلاث التي نستخدم فيها الشفرة الداخلية مع بتّين إضافيين للشفرة الخارجية. لكن لا يهم كثيراً يمكننا التفكير فيها كـ
سلسلة بطول ثابت. إليكم وصف الحالة التي نحصل عليها قبل قياس المتلازمة مباشرة حيث كل
متلازمة هي أياً كانت البتات الثمانية التي نحصل عليها من خطأ poly المقابل. لاحظ عند هذه النقطة أن النظامين
مترابطان بشكل عام وهذا فعلاً هو المفتاح لجعل كل هذا يعمل. بقياس المتلازمة ما
سنفعله فعلياً هو إسقاط الحالة إلى حالة تم فيها تطبيق إحدى عمليات poly الأربع على
الـ qubit رقم K من ψ وسنعرف من المتلازمة أي عملية poly كانت فيمكننا تصحيحها إذا
لزم الأمر. بشكل خاص إذا قسنا المتلازمة وأجرينا التصحيح المناسب فنحصل على حالة بالشكل
الموضح على الشاشة والذي بشكل حاسم هو حالة جداء. لدينا ترميزنا الأصلي غير الفاسد كـ
عامل تنسور على اليمين وهو الأهم هنا وعلى اليسار لدينا مصفوفة كثافة S تصف
متلازمة خطأ عشوائية لكن لم يعد هناك أي ارتباط مع النظام الذي يهمنا وهو
النظام على اليمين لأن الأخطاء قد تم تصحيحها. عند هذه النقطة يمكننا التخلص من qubit المتلازمة أو إعادة تعيينها
في حال أردنا استخدامها مرة أخرى وهذا في الواقع مهم جداً لأن هذه هي الطريقة التي تُزال بها العشوائية أو الإنتروبيا
الناتجة عن الأخطاء من النظام. وهكذا يعمل تكميم الأخطاء على الأقل للأخطاء
الأحادية. في جوهره بقياس المتلازمة نقوم فعلياً بإسقاط الخطأ على خطأ موصوف بـ
مصفوفة poly. للوهلة الأولى قد يبدو أنه أمر أجمل من أن يكون حقيقياً أن نتمكن من تصحيح أخطاء أحادية عشوائية
بهذه الطريقة حتى الأخطاء الضئيلة التي بالكاد يمكن ملاحظتها بمفردها. لكن المهم إدراكه
هو أن هذا خطأ أحادي على qubit واحد وبتصميم الشفرة فإن عملية على qubit واحد لا يمكنها تغيير
حالة الـ qubit المنطقي الذي يتم ترميزه. كل ما يمكنها فعله هو نقل الحالة خارج فضاء الترميزات الصالحة
لكن التصحيحات تعيدها بالضبط إلى مكانها. أخيراً لننظر فيما يحدث
عندما يحدث خطأ عشوائي ليس بالضرورة أحادياً. الإعداد هو نفسه كما سبق
شفّرنا qubit واحد في 9 باستخدام شفرة Shore وخطأ عشوائي ممثل بقناة qubit Φ
يحدث على أحد الـ qubit. كما سنرى كل شيء سينجح بنفس الطريقة تقريباً
كما حدث مع الأخطاء الأحادية والخطوة الأولى نحو التحقق من ذلك هي النظر في تمثيل Kraus للخطأ
ما يمكننا فعله الآن هو اتباع نفس المنطق تماماً كما فعلنا مع الأخطاء الأحادية باستثناء أننا نطبق ذلك
المنطق على مصفوفات Kraus بدلاً من مصفوفة أحادية واحدة تمثل الخطأ
بشكل خاص يمكن التعبير عن كل مصفوفة Kraus كتركيبة خطية لمصفوفات poly وهذا يسمح لنا بـ
التعبير عن تأثير هذا الخطأ Φ على أياً كان qubit K الذي يحدث عليه بالشكل الموضح هنا على
الشاشة. كل ما نفعله هنا هو توسيع مصفوفات Kraus كتركيبات خطية لمصفوفات poly
إذا حسبنا بعد ذلك وقسنا متلازمة الخطأ وصححنا أي أخطاء تُكشف فسنحصل على
حالة مماثلة لما حصلنا عليه في حالة الخطأ الأحادي. لن أخوض في التفاصيل فهي مشابهة جداً للحالة
الأحادية وأيضاً أصعب قليلاً في الكتابة لكن من الناحية المفاهيمية فهي واضحة
جداً. يجب أن أذكر أن كل هذا يُعمّم على شفرات تصحيح أخطاء كمية أخرى بما في ذلك شفرات تستطيع التصحيح ضد أخطاء على عدة
qubit. في تلك الحالة يمكن التعبير عن الأخطاء على عدة qubit كتركيبات خطية لجداءات تنسور لمصفوفات
poly وبالمقابل فإن المتلازمات المختلفة الممكنة ستصف تصحيحات تُجرى على عدة qubit بدلاً من واحد فقط
لكن الفكرة الأساسية هي نفسها تماماً. مرة أخرى بقياس المتلازمة
نقوم فعلياً بإسقاط أو طيّ الأخطاء إلى مجموعة منفصلة من الاحتمالات ممثلة بجداءات تنسور
لمصفوفات poly وبتصحيح تلك الأخطاء أي أخطاء poly يمكننا استعادة الحالة
المشفّرة الأصلية. وفي الوقت نفسه أياً كانت العشوائية الناتجة في العملية تنتقل إلى qubit المتلازمة التي يمكننا بعد ذلك
التخلص منها أو إعادة تعيينها وهو أمر حاسم لأن هذه هي الطريقة التي تُزال بها الإنتروبيا الناتجة عن الأخطاء وقياسات المتلازمة
من النظام. وهذا هو نهاية الدرس الذي ألقينا فيه نظرة أولى على
تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية بما في ذلك شفرة Shore ذات الـ 9 qubit وتكميم الأخطاء. أتمنى أن تنضموا إليّ في
الدرس القادم الذي سنناقش فيه شكلية المثبّتات التي توفر لنا أداة قوية لوصف و
تحليل فئة كبيرة ومثيرة من شفرات تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية بما في ذلك شفرات هي مرشحة واعدة لـ
الحواسيب الكمية الحقيقية. إلى اللقاء حتى ذلك الحين